amir ate two-thirds of a piece of red
licorice so let's draw a piece of red
licorice over here
and let's draw it into thirds
so let's split it into thirds
three equal sections as best as i can
draw that and he ate two thirds of it so
that's one-third right over here and
then this is a second third so that's
two-thirds what i shaded in this is how
much of that red licorice you would have
eaten
then they tell us nico ate two-thirds of
a longer but equally thick piece of red
licorice
so it's going to be equally thick
but it's longer so i'm just going to
draw something that is longer so that's
longer but equally thick and he also ate
two thirds of this but this is a longer
piece and it's equally thick so it's
actually going to be just a larger piece
it's going to have more licorice in it
so two-thirds of that let me see if i
can split this into
thirds and then this is one-third this
is a second third
well two-thirds of a larger piece is
going to be two is going to be more than
two-thirds of a smaller piece this right
over here this amount that he ate it has
the same width but it's longer than this
right over here
so nico because this is a
longer but equally thick piece of red
licorice nico ate more red licorice
nico for sure
let's do another one
my unicorn that's interesting to have a
unicorn my unicorn ate 2 6 of a pizza
from store a
all right
i ate 2 6 of a different pizza from
store b
who ate more pizza
well
it depends you know store a's pizza
might look like this store b's pizza
might look like this so if this was the
case so if this is store a and this is
store b you eat two sixths of this let
me divide this into six so that's
halves
that would be
and then
sixth
whoops i don't want to do eight so i
want to do sixths
so i want to do something
so
that's close enough you get the idea so
2 6 would be like this 1 6 2 6 and 2 6
of this would be
would be like this
let me do my best shot at
drawing this i'm trying to do six equal
pieces it's hard to hand draw but this
gets us close 2 6 here would be that
and that and if so store b's pizza is
bigger than store a's pizza then i would
have eaten more pizza than my unicorn
but it might have been the other way
around maybe store b's pizzas like this
and store a's pizzas like this and if
this was the case if my unicorn ate this
2 6 then the unicorn ate more or maybe
the pizzas were both this size in which
case we would have eaten the same amount
so just based on what they told us we
don't know how store b speed compares to
store a's pizza we don't know
we
don't know
whether i or my unicorn got more
got more pizza
let's do one more of these these are fun
it took hiro one third of an hour to run
from his house to school
it took fred one third of an hour to run
who took more time running to school now
this is a good one this is a good one
because at first you might say okay you
know hero might live here that's hero's
house i'll put h for hero here maybe
this is the school i'll just try to draw
a larger
larger building right here this is the
school
and you might say okay well maybe fred's
house who knows where fred's house is
fred's house could be here
it could be
it could be there it could be over here
someplace it could be
over here someplace we don't know where
fred's house is we we don't know if it's
closer or further away from than hiro's
house so you might be saying oh we we
don't know
we remember they're not saying whose
house is closer or further away or even
who ran faster they're telling us who
took more time running to school
and they directly tell us the amount of
time they took
hiro took one third of an hour to run to
school from his house to school and fred
took exactly one-third of an hour i
don't know who ran faster or slower or
who
went further distance or shorter
distance but i know that they both took
the same amount of time they both took
one third of an hour so this is the same
they both took the same
same time this question is a little bit
like the the famous brain teaser that
some people might ask you
what weighs more a pound of gold or a
pound or what would you rather have or
actually no what would i know which one
would you rather have which one weighs
more a pound of gold or a pound of
cotton and people like oh gold is
heavier than cotton maybe gold would
make but we're saying a pound of gold
versus a pound of cotton well they're
both a pound they would weigh the same
that's kind of what we're doing in this
question right over here